[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed
today it's the day that i can finally
show you
how the geforce rtx 3080 performs
and as expected we do have a boatload of
benchmark data to go over
there's also a lot of architectural
stuff that we could cover as well
and we could also explore the foundation
design and check all that sort of stuff
out
but i feel both of those things could
easily warrant their own dedicated video
and i know that most of you really just
want to see the benchmarks at this point
so
i'm going to quickly go over some of the
basic specs and then jump into the
results
but before any of that today's video was
sponsored by asus and their brand new
range of rog strix b550 motherboards
many of which we've already tested here
at harbor unboxed and found to deliver
excellent vrm thermal performance and
whatever your needs
asus has an rog strix b550 motherboard
for you
all of which come with a range of ai
features such as ai networking
ai noise cancellation technology and ai
overclocking
the b550f gaming is a particular
favorite of mine as it's competitively
priced and delivers a strong feature set
including a high quality vrm so for more
information please check the link in the
video description
okay so the new geforce 30 series is
based on the ampere architecture using
samsung's eight nanometer process
and nvidia claims this will provide a
giant leap in performance
on paper the rtx 3080 certainly looks
very mighty packing an insane
28 billion transistors that's a 50
increase over the rtx 2080 ti previously
the world's fastest gaming gpu
another big change from the turing-based
geforce 20 series has been made to the
streaming multi-processor
or sm and its 32-bit floating point or
fp32
throughput nvidia has doubled the
throughput by designing a new data path
for fp32 and
in 32 operations which results in all
four partitions combined
executing 128 fp32 operations per clock
nvidia says this helps improve gaming
performance and while true
its effectiveness will depend on a few
things which we'll explore in this
review
and now here's a side-by-side
specification comparison between the rtx
2080 and 2080 ti when compared to the
2080 ti we're looking at the same number
of sm units
with the 3080 but due to the two times
fp32 redesign
nvidia is claiming a 100 increase in
cuda cores
that specification though can be a bit
misleading as the 3080 won't be 100
faster than the 2080 ti
but it will offer a reasonable
performance uplift i suppose the point
is you can't
really make a meaningful cuda core count
comparison between
different generations something we can
directly compare
is the memory configuration whereas the
2080 ti received an 11 gigabyte memory
buffer the rtx 3080 has been cut down to
10 gigabytes
which is quite surprising and while
that's a 25 increase over the rtx 2080
you would expect a larger buffer for a
card targeting 4k gaming
that said the memory bandwidth has been
greatly increased thanks to the use of
19 gigabits per second gddr6x memory
on a 320 bit wide bus resulting in a
peak bandwidth of 706
gigabytes per second and that's a 23
increase from the 2080 ti
and 70 from the 2080. it's also worth
noting the increase in tgp
or total graphics power from 215 watts
for the rtx 2080 to 320 watts for the
rtx 3080
as that is a massive 49 increase
and even a 28 increase from the 2080 ti
so it will be interesting to see how
well the rtx 3080 founders edition
graphics card
deals with all that power once it's
converted to heat energy
but enough about all that it's time to
get into the blue bar graphs for testing
we're using the ryzen 93950x test system
featuring four sticks of low latency
ddr4 3200 memory
operating in a dual rank configuration i
also have some core i9 10900k
and pci express data that we'll look at
as well so let's get into it
starting with death stranding and here
we're looking at a 20
performance increase over the 2080 ti at
1440p
and a 41 increase over the rtx 2080. so
that's not bad
but not the 80 i suspect many of you
were expecting to see
and i should note that the margins were
identical on our core i9
10900k test system now moving to 4k
does improve the margins for the rtx
3080 and now it's 29
faster than the 2080ti and 62 percent
faster than the vanilla 2080. so that is
starting to get up there
also 107 fps on average at 4k is a very
impressive result
the game looked spectacular and as you
might imagine was very smooth
unfortunately the performance gains in
microsoft flight simulator 2020
at 1440p are very weak and this is
largely due to our choice to use the
3950x
the game just doesn't utilize ryzen
processors very well right now
and is in desperate need of low level
api support
here we're looking at a measly 9
increase over the 2080 ti
and 30 over the 2080 but even then with
an intel cpu you're still only looking
at a 20
increase over the 2080 ti jumping up to
4k
does help alleviate the cpu bottleneck
and here the 3080 was 29 faster than the
2080 ti which
i'm quite sure will disappoint many of
you and please note there is no
actual cpu limit here we saw the exact
same frame rates on our 10900k test
system
so with an rtx 3080 you're looking at
just 40 fps
4k when flying over big cities in
microsoft's flight simulator 2020.
shadow of the tomb raider was one of the
games that impressed me the most
two years ago when testing the rtx 2080
ti for the first time the 4k experience
really is amazing
at 1440p the rtx 3080 is seen to be 28
faster than the 2080 ti and 57 faster
than the 2080.
so again probably not the gains many of
you are expecting to see
but still 154 fps on average under these
conditions
is very impressive then at 4k we see
that 87fps on average is possible with
the rtx 3080 so that's pretty impressive
stuff
and that's also a 67 increase over the
2080 and 30
over the 2080 ti so both again quite
impressive gains
particularly given that this is a 700 us
gpu
moving on to tom clancy's rainbow six
siege and here we're looking at a 20
increase over the 2080 ti and at 63 over
the standard 2080 or
54 over the super version i'm probably
not going to reference the 2080 super
too much in this video given that it
only offered a mere 5
increase over the original model and
most of you probably bought the original
now at 4k we're looking at a 29 increase
over the 2080 ti
and 71 over the 2080 so those are some
pretty solid gains
it also means whereas the 2080 ti
averaged 135 fps
the 3080 saw 1 lows of 152 fps
and that'll provide a better experience
for higher refresh rate 4k
gaming next up we have the f1 2020
results and here we're seeing what's
already become a fairly typical
30ish percent boost over the 2080 ti
1440p
and this time it's a 29 performance
uplift to be exact
that meant the 3080 was 57 faster than
the vanilla 2080
so a pretty solid performance uplift
there once again we're seeing the
margins do grow a little at 4k
and now the rtx 3080 is 36 percent
faster than the 2080 ti
and 72 percent faster than the 2080
which is a far more significant margin
and much closer to the 80 percent that's
been put out there since the
announcement
it's also worth noting that we're now
talking about 129 fps on average at 4k
that is staggering performance moving on
to gears 5 and here we're seeing
pretty mild performance gains 1440p just
an 18
boost from the 2080 ti and 37 over the
standard 2080.
frankly those are pretty disappointing
gains especially given we're talking
about just a 34
improvement over the now three and a
half year old gtx 1080 ti
which also sold for 700 us
again increasing the resolution of 4k
does help out the rtx 3080 and now it's
47 faster than the gtx 1080 ti
not exactly amazing gains given how old
the pascal gpu is now
but it's really not bad either this time
we're looking at a 33
performance uplift for the rtx 3080 over
the 2080 ti
at 1440p so that's one of the better
performance gains we've seen at this
resolution so far
it also meant the new ampere-based gpu
was 76 percent fast in the gtx 1080 ti
which is a significant performance
uplift
and we also saw at almost 70 increase
over the rtx 2080 so i am very impressed
with these results
and of course they only get better at 4k
here the 3080 was a whopping 43 percent
faster than the 2080 ti
and that is a truly massive performance
uplift and i meant the 3080 was 83
percent faster than the 2080
and 92 percent faster than the 1080 ti
so those are obviously some very
impressive margins
though they do appear at this point to
be a best case scenario
for the rtx 3080. with assassin's creed
odyssey though
we're back to more mild gains at 1440p
here the rtx 3080 leads the 2080 ti by a
margin and the 1080 ti and 2080 by just
a 42
margin i know it sounds a bit strange to
be saying just
42 percent but again remember the 1080
ti cost the same amount as the 3080
it was just released three and a half
years ago all of that said
we are once again seeing more positive
margins for the 3080 at the higher 4k
resolution here it provided a 35
performance bump
over the 2080 ti and that meant it was
51 faster than the 1080ti
and 2080. though it also has to be said
that's one of the lowest gains we've
seen
at the 4k resolution for the 3080
with no help from dynamic resolution
scaling the rtx 3080 pumped out 190 fps
on average at 1440p
in world war z using the maximum in-game
quality settings
so that's a very impressive frame rate
though it is well worth noting that it's
only a
17 performance boost over the 2080 ti
and 42
over the 2080. i should also note that
while the 3950x does create a small
bottleneck in world war z at 1440p
the margins are virtually identical on
the intel core i9 10900k test system
moving by just a few percent in the
3080s favor
of course as we've seen countless times
already now moving to 4k
really does help out the rtx 3080
whereas it was just 17
faster than the 2082 at 1440p it's now
faster at 4k and that is a massive
improvement and a bit surprising given
that we see the same margins
at each resolution with the intel test
system but we do know why this is and
i'll explain shortly for now let's move
on to metro exodus
and here in metro exodus the 3950x does
actually become
a bit of a problem this is a rare
instance where the ryzen cpu does
heavily limit performance at 1440p
and as a result the rtx 3080 suffers
that said i am happy to be reporting
this data as many of you are using a
ryzen processor
and these are the gains you can expect
to see at 1440p in this title
just a 25 boost over the rtx 2080
however i should note that the 3950x
doesn't limit performance at all
at 4k so the numbers you're looking at
here are identical to those recorded
using
our 10900k test system so what we have
here is a 35
uplift over the 2080 ti and 70 over the
both of which are very impressive gains
now moving on to the resident evil 3
results where we see an impressive 196
fps on average
from the rtx 3080 when using the maximum
in-game quality settings
and that meant it was 31 faster than the
2080 ti
and 66 percent faster than the gtx 1080
ti
and rtx 2080. so a decent result here
jumping up to the 4k resolution and
we're seeing just over 100 fps on
average for a 30
boost over the 2080 ti and a massive 76
improvement over the rtx 2080 and gtx
1080 ti so again
impressive gains here and not far from
the 80
i'm sure many of you are hoping to see
do maternal is a game that's been
heavily used by nvidia to show off the
rtx 3080 performance
and you'll see why once we move to the
4k testing
at 1440p though the results aren't
overly impressive
as the 3080 was just 20 faster than 2080
ti
and 51 faster than the 2080. again i
feel 50
is an impressive gain but it's a far cry
from the 80 plus gains
we've seen in promotional materials now
moving to 4k we see some interesting
stuff using the ultra nightmare preset
which in our test sees 9 gigabytes of
vram
used here the 3080 was 35 faster than
the 2080i
but quite incredibly 115
faster than the 2080. also it was 93
faster than the 1080 ti which does well
here relative to the 2080
thanks to the extra vram but this here
is why a lot of people were claiming up
to a 100
performance gain over the 2080 after
seeing digital foundry's nvidia promo
video
the data is accurate but without more
information it can also be a bit
misleading
and here is more information by leaving
all the options on ultra nightmare
with the exception of the texture pool
size which i've dropped to ultra
reducing vram usage to 7 gigabytes
this is what we find there's no real
change in performance with gpus packing
10 gigabytes or more of vram
but for those with eight gigabytes like
the rtx 2080
we're seeing a 26 performance uplift and
that means the 3080 is now
70 faster not 115
faster we'll talk more about this soon
but for now let's move on to wolfenstein
youngblood
starting with the 1440p data we see that
the rtx 3080 is good for 242 fps on
average as it boosts the performance
over the 2080 ti
by a 22 margin and 55 over the 2080 so
fairly typical gains there for 1440p
now at 4k we're looking at 142fps on
average with the 3080 which is extremely
impressive
though that minute was again just 22
percent faster than 2080 ti
so by no means the biggest margins we've
seen it also meant that the 3080 was 60
faster than the 2080 which is a pretty
solid gain really
finally we have the hitman 2 results and
this is another rare instance where the
ryzen 9 3950x does limit performance at
1440p
and as a result the rtx 3080 is just
five percent faster than the 2080 ti
that said don't expect to see 20 or
greater margins with an intel processor
using the 10900k for example the 3080
was just 10
faster at this resolution so the gains
in hitman 2 at 1440p are very minimal
compared to what we've seen elsewhere
increasing the resolution of 4k really
does help out the 3080 as here it was 29
faster than the 2080 ti and 69 faster
than 2080
so once again we're really seeing the
amp gpu come to life at the 4k
resolution
okay so depending on what kind of
expectations you might have had coming
into this
some of these results may have been a
bit disappointing let's say while others
could have been genuinely
impressive truth is the margins we're a
bit all over the place
so let's have a look at the 14 game
average for all the gpus tested
and then we'll do a few head-to-head
comparisons looking at individual titles
starting with the 1440p data we said
that on average across the 14 games
tested the rtx 3080 was 21
faster than the 2080 ti and 49 faster
than the 2080. it was also 58 faster
than the 1080ti
and 113 faster than the vanilla 1080
so what all this means is we're looking
at roughly a 50
performance boost at the 700 price point
after two years
at least for 1440p gaming the 4k
data is certainly more favorable as here
the rtx 3080 was on average 32 percent
faster than the 2080 ti
71 faster than the rtx 2080 and 77
faster than the gtx 1080 ti those really
are far more impressive gains and it is
a bit unfortunate that the margins
weren't quite as impressive at the more
popular 1440p
resolution just quickly if we remove the
performance gain the rtx 3080 enjoyed in
doom eternal using the ultra nightmare
textures
and instead swapping the ultra texture
results we don't see that much of a
change
the 3080 is now 69 faster than the 2080
at 4k
whereas we just saw with the 115 win in
doom it was 71
faster than average so just a 2 change
in overall data
now here's a look at the margins on a
per game basis and please note due to
the way this data is calculated
there can be a small discrepancy in the
totals when comparing to the average
results we just saw
anyway as seen previously the 3080 is 21
faster than 2080 at 1440p
and here we see performance margins
range anywhere from a few percent
right up to 33 so how much extra
performance you'll see over a part like
the 2082 at 1440p
will really depend on the game and while
that's really always
true it's more so here than normal
for example we see far more predictable
margins at 4k
and this has little to do with the cpu
used and much more to do with the ampere
architecture
again i'll discuss this in more detail
soon but what we're seeing here
is gains of at least 22 percent with the
biggest margins seen in horizon zero
dawn
where the 3080 was up to 43 faster
then when compared to the rtx 2080 we're
again seeing performance that's
really all over the place at 1440p with
margins as small as 25
and then as big as 69 and there's no
real indication of what's normal or to
be expected as results are as i said
really all over the place
yet we do find far more consistent
performance at the 4k resolution
yes there is still a big difference
between 51 and 83
but looking at the data you could get
away with expecting on average around
70 percent more performance and please
note that i went with these seven
gigabyte vram data for doom here
as the 115 percent gain are using the
ultra nightmare preset is a massive
outlier right now and not indicative of
raw gpu performance
even when compared to the 1080 1440p the
margins are just all over the place you
could be looking at just 26 to 34
more performance or you could be looking
at 76 to 87
more performance so the 55 average while
accurate
isn't really a good ballpark for what
you can expect to see in a given title
again the margins are a little more
predictable at 4k though in compute
heavy titles you're looking at some
pretty massive performance gains over
pascal gpus
now let's take a look at power
consumption starting with our total
system consumption numbers
which take into account absolutely
everything in the computer so this is
power drawn from the wall
so again literally everything inside the
pc is being measured here
and this is useful for a few reasons
firstly it lets you know roughly what
kind of power supply you need
for a certain configuration it also lets
you know just how much
difference in power draw there is
between say a 2080 ti
and 3080 when factoring in the entire
system
in this instance we're looking at a
pretty big 21 increase in total
system usage as the rtx 3080 pushes our
test system up to 523 watts
that's well beyond what we saw with even
the gtx 1080 ti
or vega 64. so while certainly very fast
the rtx 3080 does suck down a lot of
power
using nvidia's pcat or power capture
analysis tool we can accurately measure
the power draw
of just the graphics card including not
only what it draws from the pcie power
connectors
but also the pcie slot it's a seriously
impressive tool and i would like to just
thank nvidia for providing it to
reviewers
that was very cool of them here we can
see that the rtx 3080 does consume
25 percent more power than the 2080 ti
and 29
more than the rtx 2080 so while that is
a lot of power it is
technically more efficient and proving
that we have some performance per watt
figures
taken from our 4k do maternal test using
the 7 gigabyte textures which
don't eight gigabyte cards like
the rtx 2080.
here we're seeing that the rtx 3080 does
offer the most performance per
watt so you can't deny its efficiency
though having said that you'd probably
be hoping for more than an eight percent
improvement over turing
from a node shrink now for testing
thermal performance of the rtx 3080
founders edition graphics card i've
installed it in our corsair obsidian
500d test system
and let it run for an hour in f1 2020
while maintaining a room temperature of
21 degrees
after which point the gpu peaked at just
77 degrees and maintained a core clock
frequency of around 1830 megahertz
this saw the graphics card fans spin at
up to 1900 rpm where they could be heard
but they weren't overly loud
unfortunately though i don't have any
scientific sound measurements right now
but still i found the fe model very good
and given the performance and power draw
i was pleasantly surprised
that said i should note that it does
squeal quite a lot when pumping out over
300 fps
so if you are sensitive to coil wine
type noises
a frame cap will be in order now perhaps
the most
important metric of them all is cost per
frame and at 700
us the rtx 3080 will be delivering the
goods
you all know that we really liked the
value that the 5700 xt offered and here
we're seeing despite offering a 64
performance boost the 380 is able to
roughly match the cost per frame
of the navi based gpu so pretty
impressive stuff there
it's also 33 cheaper per frame when
compared to the rtx 2080
however if we look at the 4k performance
the cost per frame gets
even better here the rtx 3080 is the
most affordable graphics card released
in the last four years when it comes to
cost per frame
beating even the base model rx 5700
now here's a quick look at dlss and ray
tracing performance in wolfenstein
youngblood and please note that i will
have a much more detailed analysis of
these technologies in a dedicated video
on the channel in a few days time
for now though we see when enabling ray
tracing the rtx 3080 suffers a 38
performance hit which is better than the
46 performance hit the 2080 ti suffers
then if we enable dlss with road tracing
the 3080 drops just 20
of its original performance which is
marginally better than the 25
drop we see with the 2080 ti so in that
regard
they aren't really that much different
the rtx 3080 is just faster to begin
with
when just using dlss on its own we saw a
16 performance boost which really isn't
that much different to the 12
boost we saw from the 2080 ti so let's
take a look at the 4k
data here the rtx 3080 was good for 142
fps when running at the native
resolution without any rtx features
enabled
enabling ray tracing did reduce
performance by 41
to 84 fps on average which is very
reasonable performance at 4k
but it is also still a massive fps drop
for comparison the rtx 2080 ti saw a 49
drop so not a huge difference there in
the margins
the same is also true when using dlss
the 2080 i saw an 18 performance boost
whereas the 3080 saw a 23
performance boost so really for the most
part it looks like the 3080 is faster at
stuff like ray tracing
because it's a faster gpu not because
the second gen rt calls are massively
improved
anyway we have much more ray tracing and
dlss testing to do so this is certainly
not our final conclusion on these
technologies with ampere
now something that i talked about quite
a bit in the lead up to the geforce 30
series was its use of pci express 4.0
and it was part of the reason why we
switched to an amd ryzen test system
i did have the rtx 3090 more in mind for
this but i'm also keen to see how pcie
4.0 helps out the rtx 3070
at 4k given it only has 8 gigabytes of
vram but in the meantime here are the
3080 results
basically pcie 4.0 support makes a
little difference for the rtx 3080 right
now
that could change in the future but for
now at least you're looking at no
difference at 4k
and about a 3 improvement at 1080p so
for now it's not really worth worrying
about and that was likely going to be
the case
the truth is there are a number of
reasons why we switched from intel to
amd
all of which were outlined in those
videos discussing the change but a big
reason was the fact that at the end of
the day
it doesn't really matter it won't
influence the end result
or manipulate stuff like cost per frame
for example here we're looking at how
the 3950x and 10900k compare with the
rtx 3080
and 2080 ti at 1440p across our 14 game
sample
the 10900k was four percent fast with
the 2080 ti
and six percent faster with the 3080
that two percent
isn't going to skew the results then at
4k we see there's no difference to speak
of as both cpus push the rtx 3080 to the
same 108 fps on average
so as i said back then it really
shouldn't matter which cpu a reviewer
chooses to use
as they should come to the same
conclusion with either cpu when
reviewing the rtx 3080
well there you have it the rtx 3080 in a
nutshell
i've got a lot more benchmarks i want to
show you guys and certainly a lot more
that i want to run
but i think for now we do have a pretty
good idea of what's on offer here
but before i start to break down the
data and analyze the rtx 3080
please note that i don't want to over
hype it but i also don't want to
downplay it either
that said i feel like nvidia has set
themselves up a bit here
especially with the content they ran on
the digital foundry channel
right after the announcement now i don't
want to get too bogged down in all of
that but i feel it is important to
mention
especially given how we know so many of
you were expecting to see 80
gains over the rtx 2080 as the norm and
that's certainly a bit of a disconnect
from reality given that we only saw two
examples of 80
gains at 4k one of them being due to a
vram limitation and do maternal
though that might have also been the
case with horizon zero dawn
still a 70 performance uplift on average
over the rtx 2080 4k
is obviously very impressive and a huge
improvement in cost per frame
so well done there buying video however
an area of concern for me was the
inconsistent 1440p
performance that saw the rtx 3080 beat
the 2080
by as much as 70 percent but also by as
little as 25 percent
and in the end we saw just shy of a 50
performance gain on average
now a 50 performance gain is still great
to see
admittedly though it's not super amazing
given that
it's over a two year period and really
it has been three and a half years since
the gtx 1080 ti was released
but it is also a lot better than
anything else we've received at the high
end
in that same time period before digging
into that let's talk about the
somewhat underwhelming 1440p results at
least relative to what we saw at 4k
why was the rtx 3080 performance
inconsistent at 1440p
and overall much lower than what we saw
at 4k
the reason is mostly down to the ampy
architecture
and the change to the sm configuration
that i spoke of at the start of the
video
the two times fp32 design can really
only be fully utilized at 4k
and beyond and this is because at 4k the
portion of the render time per frame is
heavier on fp32 shaders
at lower resolutions like 1440p for
example the vertices and triangle load
is identical
to what we see at 4k but at the higher
resolution pixel shaders and computer
effect shaders are much more intensive
so take longer and therefore can fill
the sms fp32 fp32alus better
that said we do often see high
performance gpus better utilized at high
resolutions
for similar reasons so that in itself
isn't that unusual
higher resolutions always do a better
job of putting core heavy gpus to work
and they also help minimize other system
bottlenecks the 2080 ti for example
extends its lead over the 2080 at 4k
as well going from 23 faster at 1440p
to 28 faster at 4k and that's with the
lower quality textures in
doom that said we're only talking about
a 5 performance discrepancy here
and the scaling at 1440p and 4k does
look very similar
and the 3950x can also be blamed for a
small part of the difference
with the rtx 3080 we're talking about a
21 margin over the 2080 ti at 1440p
and then a much larger 32 margin at 4k
and vram plays no role in that
difference as i said the issue is
largely with the ampere architecture
which is a compute heavy data center and
ai architecture
not a gaming architecture i do wonder if
nvidia has shot themselves a little bit
in the foot here
that said it's probably not going to
matter too much given that i do expect
any stock that they have on hand just
fly out the door the second these things
go on sale
but for those of you who were expecting
gains of 80
seeing just shy of 50 on average at
1440p
is probably going to be a bit
disappointing and for me it's the 1440p
data that really was a bit of a letdown
and that really is entirely because of
expectations
set by nvidia and their insistence of
showing a best case scenario and then
we're still
using digital foundry's credibility to
push those marketing claims
making them appear highly credible which
convinced many gamers
they were getting an 80 performance
improvement at the
700 us price point so in reality most
2080 owners are going to be looking at
on average a 50
performance boost as i suspect a good
many of you are targeting high refresh
rate 1440p
and not 4k gaming the fact that the 3080
excels at 4k gaming is also a little bit
unfortunate given nvidia only paired it
with 10 gigabytes of vram
and i'm just guessing here but i suspect
in a year or two you might start running
into the same kind of issues
we see in do maternal with 8 gigabyte
cards at 4k
using the maximum textures the game
still runs fine
but there is a performance penalty to
pay though pcie 4.0 will be
a lot more useful in mitigating those
performance losses
anyway blocking out any expectations you
or i might have had
a 50 performance boost on average at
1440p
is still very good at least relative to
the geforce 20 series
we only have to look at the cost per
frame data to see that the rtx 3080 is a
massive improvement over the rtx 2080 in
terms of value
and it's even better value than the rtx
and comparable to the rx 5700 xt
that being the case i think that in the
current market the geforce rtx 3080 is
an excellent value product
but it has obviously been helped by an
overpriced geforce 20 series
actually here's a bit of an example i
feel the rtx 2080 ti
should have cost 700 u.s 800 at the very
most
but let's say it was 700 dollars it
would have offered
gtx 1080 ti owners 30 more performance
for the same money and that would have
actually made it a
more significant upgrade than the 3080
over the 700
2080 ti which only nets you about 20
more performance at 1440p
so that's very interesting to think
about but ultimately it doesn't change
anything
as the 2080 ti unfortunately didn't cost
in fact it didn't really even cost the
promised 1 000
for aib cards but instead sold for more
like twelve hundred dollars u.s
therefore once again we'll be pinning
our hopes for a more competitive gpu
market
on amd so fingers crossed but i'm not
gonna hold my breath on that one
but i do feel as though nvidia has given
them an opportunity to strike back with
a gamer focused architecture
but we'll just have to wait and see on
that one as for ray tracing and dlss
while performance does look a lot better
and again we'll explore that in a
dedicated video soon
my opinion hasn't really changed on that
stuff and again the game lists
just far too limited but i am glad to
see that it hasn't been used as a key
selling point of these new amp gpus
it's now just a nice bonus and i'll talk
more about that in an upcoming video as
i said
lastly we have the issue of power
consumption and this
is a bit of a weakness of the new
geforce 30 series but ultimately
i'm not quite sure yet how much it
really matters most of you already will
have a
watt or better power supply and that
really is plenty for running an rtx
3080.
also although we are yet to look at any
aib models i'm happy to report that
nvidia's founder's edition ran
cool and quiet especially given the
performance but we're not really seeing
much of an improvement in efficiency but
again i don't think that's going to
spoil the experience for gamers in any
way
so it's hard to say how much that
matters right now overall i'd say that i
am very pleased with what the geforce
rtx 3080 is delivering at the 700
price point it's a hell of a lot better
than what we got with the last
generation
personally i would not have bought an
rtx 2080
but i would buy an rtx 3080 though i'd
probably hold off a little bit just to
see what amd has to offer
you might be forced to do that anyway
i've heard there is very limited stock
available and retailers are expecting to
sell out instantly
anyway well you guys hit refresh on your
browsers and scramble to try and buy one
of these things
i'm going to end this video and carry on
with a lot more benchmarking that i want
to do
so that is going to do it for this one
if you enjoyed this what i hope was a
detailed benchmark
review of the rtx 3080 then give it one
of those
subscribe because there's a lot more
things we want to look at
we've got a in-depth amd versus intel
cpu comparison with this thing so you
can
see those results how they differ in
certain games under certain conditions
pci express stuff we'll probably do a
in-depth analysis
of the cooling performance of the fe
card compared to aib cards there will be
an aib review of at least one card
tomorrow night in the channel so make
sure you see that that should be quite
interesting i'll be comparing the
performance of the fe card with the aib
card that i have on hand
as i sort of film this i'm not sure how
many aib cards i'll have but i should
have at least one
anyway enough from me you can support us
on patreon join us there if you want to
uh we're going to be doing a live stream
tomorrow night at
roughly this time probably an hour after
this video went live
tim and myself will be discussing this
card obviously
and addressing any questions from our
patreon members live so if you're
interested in that
jump over our patreon page you'll also
get access to stuff like our discord
chat behind the scenes videos q a's all
that cool stuff so check it out if you
are interested
if not perfectly fine and i would like
to just thank you for watching this
long rtx 3080 video thank you very much
for that
i'm your host steve and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you